[Applause]
welcome to apigee up close
webinar series they happen twice a month
the topics are based on popular demand
you can ask live questions or send them
in advance
and i am nasir muhammad a customer
solution
architect at google and i specialize in
api security
joining me in this webinar is chris page
a customer solution architect
as a part of agenda today i will start
with a brief overview of apigee edge
then we'll deep dive into apigee
security
and then i will hand it over to chris
who will demonstrate the threat
protection aspect of security
while we are doing so please post your
questions in
and we will answer them at the end let's
start with quick
apigee edge overview this is our design
philosophy at apogee
this challenges traditional approaches
of api management traditionally they
think about this from an
exposure point of view they expose a set
of services
and publish an api catalog and they
think that job is done
well not really thinking about it from
an end user point of view
and working backwards from there leads
to better results
realizing the importance of each actor
on this chain
and providing them with enhanced
experiences
becomes the key for a successful api
program
this outsiding approach is the
underlying principle at
apogee using which we have shown great
success
to many of our clients having said that
let's change the lens and look at this
pattern from a security point of view
indeed the pattern covers a lot of
ground which opens up
a need for a larger set of security
controls
each actor on this chain has unique set
of security requirements
let us start from left to right
following the outside in approach
as we publish our apis for end users how
can we protect these apis from hackers
who are trying to bring our systems down
and from data scrapers and bad bots
who wants to steal our data thereby
leading to the next question how can i
know the incoming calls are from legit
users
and do they really have needed
permissions to
access these apis an enterprise can have
many applications that access your api
how can i uniquely identify these
applications
more importantly as we are looking at it
from a security and governance
perspective
how can i ensure that the decommissioned
apps can no longer access this api
moving further in towards the right of
the chain comes the app developer
app developer uses our apis to create
great applications
now how can we onboard these app
developers remember these app developers
can be internal employees
third-party partners and any developer
on internet
how can we register him and provide him
with needed access
without much friction moving towards the
apis and api teams
how do we ensure that the api developers
are developing apis that are secure
and are not opening up any vulnerability
are they adhering to enterprise
security standards finally
on the back end how do we authenticate
back-end
how do we pass in the originating users
information to the back-end services
how do we secure data on wire and data
at rest
yeah the list is long we need an api
platform
that provides effective solution for all
these questions
apigee as a comprehensive api platform
provides standards based adaptive
security controls
addressing those diverse set of security
requirements
rpg protects against hackers and data
scrapers
leveraging the apigee sense module which
is a behavior-based
threat protection module apigee protects
our apis
against threatening content attacks like
sql injections cross-site scripting
attacks
leveraging the signature based threat
protection policy
apigee effectively controls spikes in
traffic thereby protecting our back-end
services from going down
apogee identifies the applications based
on
api keys and authenticates end user
leveraging the industry standard oauth
protocol
after identification and authentication
comes the challenge of api authorization
rpg introduces this concept of products
api products help you slice and dice
your apis
in ways that makes business sense
these products in turn act as coarse
grain
authorization enforcers
for finer grain authorization apigee
leverages
oauth scopes apart from that products
have assigned coders for enforcing usage
boundaries
and last but not the least logging
capabilities for auditability
thus covering identification
authentication
authorization and auditability aspects
of security
apigee works with your identity and
access management products like
siteminders
ping federate octa forge rock etc
for providing single sign-on and
self-service
experiences for your app developers
apigee supports
open id connect chart and sample
protocols
to work with your partners in a
federated fashion
apigee provides global policies and flow
hooks for
abstracting development and enforcement
of security policies
from business api developers
apigee provides developer portal as well
as management apis for provisioning and
decommissioning
apps and application developers apigee
secures data on wire
and in transact leveraging one way in
two ways or so
apigee can also store your sensitive
configuration elements in
encrypted fashion thereby providing
confidentiality
of your persisted data this is a high
level overview of
abigail's security landscape in this
webinar
we will concentrate on the threat
protection policies
with that i will hand it over to chris
hi i'm chris page
i'm a customer solution architect on the
apigee team
which is part of google cloud today i'm
going to showcase how apigee edge can be
configured to protect against threat
protection
so the problem is when a malicious
client
can send malform requests to your
backend services as showcased in my
diagram below
this includes all components that make
up the http request or message from
those clients
whether it be tls certificates
request headers the payload or even the
query string
fields and or parameters now a client
can be
anything it can be a browser a mobile
device
a server or even an iot device the api
proxy layer
should detect block and report any
malform requests that are received from
those clients
before the requests are processed on the
backend systems
too often this is an oversight and is
not implemented
or not even a priority when developers
are building out back-end systems
owasp which is the open web application
security project is an open community
that is dedicated to enabling
organizations to implement web and api
security best practices
oas publishes a top 10 list of the most
critical security risks to web
applications and apis
their latest publication last year
labeled injection falls as the number
one
security risk in this demo we'll cover
two of those topics
input validation which user supplied
data is not validated
filtered or sanitized before the
application receives it it should only
be applied
to both syntactical and semantic levels
that's
like structured fields and or value
ranges
i.e only permit valid payloads or depths
and lengths
a key value is one depth whereas
key key 2 key 3 would be multiple depth
and also validate query parameter fields
i.e
for this demo i'm only going to validate
the limit name
and brewery key fields another example
of injection fall is a sql code
injection
i.e when dynamic queries
are calls without any contextual wear
escaping are used to directly
hit the interpreter or the application
context
i.e let's search on the filter for
parameter values
where name equals delete from resource
this can be applied um in addition to
not just relational but also nosql
queries
and a lot of times it can be implemented
on orm levels or object relational
mapping
abstraction layers from the database
that may have direct
sql queries implemented as well now
there's
in this diagram on the right hand side
there is a restful beer service
that is returning valid json data to
client
we want to only allow good requests from
valid clients
and detect block
and report on the bad requests from
those malicious clients
the goals are create an api that
protects
against those injection flaws from the
client requests payloads and query
parameters
keep it as simple as possible make it
reproducible for any
additional apis and also be able to
report on the usage
of those malformed requests now let's
get to the api
let's log into my apigee edge account
and take a look at the proxy that i've
already created
for this demo
my proxy my beers proxy um already has a
deployment url
um you can see my fqdn here with the
endpoint of ford slash v1 forward slash
beer
here's my target endpoint or my back-end
beer service
called v1 beer-back-end
once let's take a look at the actual
policies that we can run through
with this proxy you'll see that
i have a couple policies that are
already defined here
out of the box apogee edge includes
a whole different a whole suite of
pallets a whole palette of
different policy assertions with every
traffic management security
mediation for transformation as well as
extendability
um today we're just going to focus on a
couple of the threat protections
um json threat protection for input
validation
as well as a sql code projection and
parameter validation for injection flaws
so on my details flow i've already went
ahead and created the json threat
protection
parameter validation leveraging a
javascript callout
i also have a custom fault detection for
that javascript parameter
validation and then also sql code
protection
in a real world production api proxy
you would also have some authenticity to
identify
the client as well as any ib tables or
restriction based
rules before any of these additional
policies
let's take a look at json threat
protection as our first policy
we'll see that there's a couple
different um
parameters or variables that are defined
here our right element count
is the first one that means that this
json
structure will not include any arrays
it will just actually be a key value and
the depth of those values will just be
one
so there won't be any nested depth or
nested
key value objects within the json
structure
we're going to keep the number of keys
or the number of entries to three
and we're going to keep the length of
those keys down to 50.
in addition we're going to limit the
value
of those keys to only be 255 characters
now apogee edge
provides a real-time trace debugger so
we can actually go ahead
and start looking at the requests coming
in i'll start with a couple successful
requests
so that you can see that nothing is
going to be triggered and then simulate
some of the
the more the input validation
and injection flaws
just minimize this
awesome so first let's just do a simple
get
oh there's a return let's actually
limit to one resource there's a simple
beer
coming back let's try a filter
equals two
excellent you'll see that the
first three requests came through as two
hundreds
i can ignore that fat finger 404 that i
just did
if we do a simple post let's create a
new beer
um we'll just have a simple name be
i have a post with application content
or content type application json the
name
the payload is a json structure with
name and the value of the best beer
so i got a 201 return back from my
response
perfect everything looks good now let's
try and actually simulate some of that
input validation
to trigger those policies that i already
have enabled
so for json threat protection let's run
through two examples
of let's do nested json and extremely
large key values
um so that we can trigger and identify
which ones are actually being captured
so first things first let's try that
post again
this time i'm going to do a nested
structure as my value
instead of just a standard name
oh immediately i got a 400 back
from my apogee edge
api proxy you'll see that i have a
custom fault string or fault message
that is actually
identifying the policy itself which is
json threat protection and more details
of
exceeded the container depth at line one
and we look at
our our trade session and there's that
400
and if you walk through the trace path
you'll see that that
json threat protection was triggered
right here excellent
now what if i have a random array of
strings
that are over 255 characters let's try
that same post method this time with
there it is 400 immediately back from
apogee edge
my api proxy and you'll see the same
policy was triggered json threat
protection with a different value though
this time
exceeded string length string value
length at line one
likewise there it is i got the error
right here on the json threat protection
now each time that actually occurs i'm
actually doing some additional
um logging you'll see these other
policies here that i'll get into
where i'm going to capture those error
codes and be able to report on later
but this this showcases that um with a
simple
drag and drop policy you can configure
and have those parameters defined to
about a against json threats or within
the key as well as the value and the
structure itself
now for the next example let's take a
look at
sql code injection flaws um as well
as parameter url parameter query strings
so let's go back to my policies
on my detail um policy flow
now i have a couple additional policies
out next to my json threat protection
the first one is parameter validation
and for parameter validation i'm
actually going to leverage our
javascript call
out feature where i can write custom
javascript and custom logic with an
apogee edge
to manipulate the message or session as
well as define custom variables
um from the request coming in
so within my parameter validation
javascript i'm actually going to create
a white list
of parameters or query strings that
are only valid for my back-end client in
this case
i only want to allow the query string
name brewery and limit to be able to
pass
the pass back to my backend resource
um i set a custom fault response message
here so that i can capture it if this
we're this parameter validation
protection is triggered and i'm actually
going to go
and iterate over the request parameters
um
i'll do i'll iterate over the whitelist
to see if any of those request
parameters
meet one of those variables in the white
list then if
i'll flag one if they're true they're
good
if not i'll flag them as false and i'll
actually set
a context variable called parameter
validation fault
to set a custom fault message so that i
can report on that accordingly
once that custom fault message is set um
i'll actually raise
i'll set a custom primary validation
fault message here i'll be able to
report on that accordingly let's go back
to my trade session
um we're still running great
let's set um let's simulate a successful
call again
with those query strings you'll see
there's that best braille that i just
created earlier
now if i change my query parameter in
addition to limit and name
if i add let's say test equals 1 2 3
which was not a valid
parameter immediately i get a 400 back
from
my apogee edge api proxy
and here's a different definition or a
different
um policy name parameter validation
execution failed reason test is not a
valid parameter that is true
that wasn't one of those white listed
parameters that i defined in my
my javascript callout and you'll see
right here
that i'm not the json threat protection
was not triggered
but the actual the um
parameter validation went through i
iterated over those
three values and then i set the this
fault
that this was triggered and then i
caught that fault and i raised the fault
based off that
my parameter validation
just as like that you can have white
listed parameters
that you can call out in addition to
json threat protection for
injection flaws now what if the client
is going to send
those now form sql code
let's go back to my my do
my policy and here is sql code
this is actually a sql code protection
policy where i'm
allowing amazing edge to
identify the invalid
sql that is being sent by the values of
those query parameters with a name
so whether it be the query the header or
the form
i am looking i have a set red regex
which was defined by owasp where delete
execute drop
insert shutdown or update or any other
standards
relational sql or nosql queries
can be captured and this policy can be
triggered
so let's take another example let's go
back to my trace session
so if i do a get this time
let's change name to be delete
from
brewery let's try that
oh just like that once again i got
another 400 back
from my abigail jpi proxy
and you'll see this time it's regular
expression detected
and actually i'm identifying delete from
brewery was the valid
invalid um parameter or an invalid
um value for that parameter i go back to
my trace session
let's skip over here and you'll see that
the
sql code protection was actually
triggered this time
just like that i just in those three
policies
i was able to do input validation
through nested json and json string
length
as well as injection flaws from query
parameters and
sql code injection failures now i did
mention
that i needed to capture
i had some additional policies to
capture um
those analytics because the idea of the
proxy is not just
to detect and block those threat
protections
but also report on them too so
i have these additional um fault
response
fault response flows right down here
where i'm going to
extract the error codes that are coming
back from this fall response
i'm going to try and capture that error
code variable
um so that i can report on them to our
apigee edges analytics
now that value right here is actually
just
a key value error code with
the value here it is steps ray x
protection and if i look at the other
one
it is steps parameter validation so what
within this policy i'm actually doing a
json path
on that variable or on that detail error
code variable and then saving that
as a context variable called fault error
code
that fault error code is now going to be
leveraged um through our fault collector
and that this fault collector is
basically a statistics collector
that will capture that variable and set
it as
a new value within our analytics so that
i can report on it
so that fault error code variable will
actually be set as full underscore error
underscore
code within my analytics i went ahead
and already created a report let's see
if that is
available it reports on those error
codes
based off of the sum of traffic
so if i go into this report
oh there it is you'll see that i am
capturing um
each one of them looks like there's the
threat protection here's the parameter
validation
here's a regulus protection looks like i
have a couple
ones that are not set that i'll have to
go back and clean up to make sure that
they're not being sent
um anonymously but just like that um
you're able to protect um with an apogee
edge
for threat protection of injection flaws
as well as input validation and then
report on them
within our analytics platform and that
concludes
this demo thank you very much let me
know if you have any questions
thank you for for really really
wonderful demo there
alright so we'll take a pause here for
questions and answers
so guys uh please do you ask your
questions
i'll be following through the q a
channel here
so the first question in here uh goes as
follows
can apigee be configured to detect
false positives while performing uh
signature-based threats using our
current graph
and a cloud-based firewall we can block
the calls
that have threatening signatures but
they do not tell us
why the calls were blocked can apigee
provide
additional information on why the
request was blocked
so that's the question yeah and uh
yeah so you know we have seen this
before uh from
many of our clients as well um who are
using
graphs or any firewall in the networks
right
um when it comes to technical
protection it is very important for us
to get the signatures
right at times what happens because you
know you might have a signature
uh regular expression that corresponds
to a signature
and it might it might also capture or
mark
the requests that are not really the
main content
uh or you know the request that did not
really have any content that was
threatening
but was a false positive so yes in
apigee
you can configure your setting content
policies to report back
on to why the call was uh blocked
thereby
you know your developers can go back and
uh can see why the call was blocked or
it can go to your
uh you know analytics consoles or your
logging systems with
uh whereby the the operations folks can
go and see why a particular transaction
was blocked
hope that answers that question so the
next question
i have here is can apigee be integrated
with cloud-based
identity solutions like after
yes uh we have many of our time so using
archer and
uh are also using apigee for api
management
the the general answer like yes the
answer is yes for author but in general
for any cloud identity
uh solution as long as the
cloud identity provider supports a saml
uh protocol or open id connect protocol
we can work with them
uh we have also worked with some of the
cloud providers that
really do not support a fully organized
content protocol but
they have uh oauth implementation
um which we can integrate with as well
so the short answer is yes we support
aksha the cloud-based identity solution
so there's another question here how can
i configure
behavior based thread protection module
uh like where where can i set the upper
limits and lower limits
of uh for example a brute force attack i
so that's interesting so
uh what we have seen in this demo today
is signature based
threat protection right so there's also
a complimentary aspect of signature
baseball protection which is also known
as like you know
a behavior-based threat protection
apigee has a product called apigee sense
that does uh provide those capabilities
and
apigee sense provides uh you know it's
basically
what it provides you uh settings that
are based on convention based on our
experiences
as to how you mark a certain attack as a
brute force attack or a password guess
or attack right
and then out of those settings we give
full control to
our customers to come and uh fine-tune
those settings based on their needs
so yes uh you know apigee that provides
you configuration
capabilities to configure your
behavior-based detection algorithms
based on your inputs you know so
i hope that answers that question okay
let me check on one of these other
next question does sql code protection
only apply to relational databases
now that's um you know yes i know
there's a
common misconception that if developers
are not writing sql queries for nosql
databases
that sql code injection is really not
applicable
there are definitely well-known nosql
vulnerabilities via associated arrays
and where clauses
you can definitely check out on some of
the black cap and
oauth websites but there's some
documentation for testing
against sql code on nosql data stores
sounds good so the next question that is
in here is uh
should an orm database
framework library handle all sql
injection protection
that's a good question so uh you know
the best practices for security is to
block the threatening content
before it comes to your uh you know to
further uh
that are like you know on the database
side so for example let's say
your orm basically sits in your internet
right where the data is
so the fact that the threat thing uh
content vector reached and managed to
reach
reached uh reach at that level and
itself is a risk
so you know we definitely want our orm
databases to implement
sql injection protections all right but
it should be handled on the edge of the
api data layers so that you know we
provide
at the first level of defense which is
our api gateway
of making sure that there's no
threatening ventures or
signatures that are coming in and
protected over there so the answer is
yes
you know the protection should be on the
orm
as well but it is always a best practice
to protect the cause at the edge layers
so i'll take up the second and the next
question as well here
can apigee prevent the malicious
requests
or can it only detect if it can prevent
can this prevented malicious malicious
calls be reported
to our incident management teams that's
a good question so
yes apigee is both detection
works both as a detection and prevention
mechanisms so it has detective controls
and it has preventative controls as well
apigee can very well like uh christian
in the demonstrations that
can detect and prevent and block the car
right there
if you want apigee can also detect
and report the call i think that's the
question that's where the question was
leading towards right
so it can definitely uh detect and
uh you know notify an incident
management team to take appropriate
actions obviously the preferred approach
is to prevent
and detect at apigee and after a
detection
block the call and then notified to the
incident management team so that the
incident management team can take
appropriate options actions on that
hope that answers that question chris
you want to go for the next one
sure do you here's a question do you
have to have
customized sql injection regex for
threat protection or something universal
or something universal which can be used
so it is there's a wide range
of threat protections um that
can be identified from the communities
and there isn't
one unique regex that would solve all
so you basically define those unique
regex patterns based off of that
particular threat
this next one is there a list
of out-of-the-box security policies that
you would recommend to use as a starting
point for most apis
now that's um you know that's a good
question you know a lot of times we hear
that you know
what what are those best practices from
our customers of
what security policies should be applied
um
to those apis and it's really going to
depend
um what type of api it is is that you
know is it a soap based
service is it a restful service um
you know is there is it a public spacing
is it an internal okay
we have um you know a lot of those
threat protections we would
definitely implement for those apis
right out of the box
we also have a couple other policies
within our palette that we didn't
go into depth within this this tutorial
or this webinar um
some like um verifying
um client quota or rate limiting or
spike arrest would also be applied as
best practices
and you can find out more of them
through our community and our doc sites
within the resources tab
i have a few questions here which are
related
how do you validate the input request
parameters
with the data types example if i want to
send a
h parameters i would not like to take a
character input
so that question and the question about
it um
also can we evaluate the url parameters
and uh
body failures validating against uh a
json schema so
you know it's a data validation question
yes we you can validate your in input
incoming requests against like json
schema or xml schema
and the schema validation is definitely
a very first step for you to validate
the data
um you can definitely do that what you
can
also do is uh you know because we are
focused on threatening content
protection right
we can also validate the complexity
of the json there are you know there are
a few attacks that are sophisticated in
the nature that like you know they
they try to uh emulate a denial of
service attack
by sending a huge json payload or an xml
payload that your back-ends cannot
handle
right so apigee can definitely
um you know rapidly has this uh
complexity policy
where you can define your complexity
levels saying that
you know the the allowed max
cap or number of elements in a json um
payload is let's say 50. so you know
anyone who's trying to send
more than that we will mark that as a as
a twit
right right so that we can do that so
the answer is
uh data validation can be done via
schema
xml teamwork in case of schemas you can
actually go
a fine grain and you can pick the query
parents
or http headers and also validate the
data
by using your script filters and then uh
you can take that to the next level
where you're also adding the complexity
filters
on top of it hope that answers that
question this is a great question
i think of course we went through all
the questions here there is
uh the question also let's say i want to
be an
expert in apigee what do i need to do
so um you know apigee has
so first thing you have to do is uh log
in
create an account start using apigee the
more you use the more use cases you
implement you know
uh the more you learn about uh about the
the product itself but having said that
um
if you want to become an expert in
apigee you you know you also broaden
your view of uh api platform it's not
just the api gateway
it is built to it right like we uh
started in the slide right there's
a developer portal in apigee there's
also
how you know our recommendations on how
do you document your api
how do you publish your api you know
apart from security there are more
uh more other features that you know uh
that are there that apigee provides
there are also regional api jam sessions
which we conduct you can you're free to
uh join any of those sessions uh wherein
it's a one day session
you come in um and it's a
i think it's a a fire fireworks session
where it's a deep dive into the product
you're basically building apis
configuring developer photos and all
that
by the end of that you would uh actually
become an api ninja
so look on uh watch out for these
api regional api exam sessions if you
want
a specific api jam session for your
organization we are
you know you're more than welcome to
send out a request and we'll do the best
to cater that
looks like there's about one or two more
questions i can take these
uh this year why
isn't the client authenticated
before the threat protections um i guess
i think the way i interpret it is why is
there the client not identified
before these threats protections are
implemented
or exercised well in a real world you
know api security best practices yes
the client really should be
authenticated before
inspecting that payload queries et
cetera to identify
really which client and you know what
client is sending the malicious data
you know best practices are fail fast
before you know requiring additional
system resources
for inspection of you know the request
payload
typically off n or auth disease would be
covered will be covered in a future
apogee up close and security webinar how
can
it does it applies adaptive api security
um
its product to mitigate sophisticated
bot attacks
it leverages machine learning and
detects anomalies
based off pattern batching at the api
layer
you as an administrator have the ability
to create dynamic rules or custom rules
um based off of that pattern matching
that the
product provides also enables you to
take action on those bots
bocce fun whether it be throttle block
log etc
and we also have another session within
apogee
apogee sense that is coming up in a
couple weeks
i think that's it for the questions um
appreciate everyone's input i'd just
like to um
leave off with some follow-up
documentation
our next webcast is tuesday march 6 how
secure your apis
we also have a in-depth tutorial you can
join vr
virtual api jam and for any one-on-one
sessions or additional
questions please reach out to michael
lockquist
his email is m
lofquest l-o-f-q-u-i-s-t at google.com
and all additional documentation links
are in the resources section
and that's wrap appreciate everyone
joining this web
webcast today look forward to seeing the
next one